With dozens of reasons to love 'em, eggs are one of our best food buys.
So today, we came to an egg farm...
...to get a behind-the-scenes look at just how one of our most preferred foods gets from the hen houses to our houses.
And it all starts in a temperature-controlled hen house,...
...where hens are treated to a healthy blend of feed that's packed with vitamins and corn and soy bean.
Well, in fact, they probably eat a better balanced diet than most people.
And apparently the hens are early risers,...
...because most of the eggs are laid in the morning.
You see, the eggs drop automatically onto the conveyor belt...
...before being moved down the line..
...where they're washed and sanitized,...
...making sure that they're nice and clean.
And here alone, they produce more than one and a half million eggs every single day.
Now next, the cameras take photos of every egg...
...and computers check them out to make sure that each meets strict standards,...
...before every egg is rated based on size and quality.
And finally, the eggs are carefully packed, and boxed and delivered to our markets.
Did you know that the average egg is in our market within 24 hours of being laid?
Now, that's farm fresh.